The Joe Rogan Experience what happened
with you and Colby
uh he's a [__] bro he showed his true
colors for the money for the
pay-per-view he talked about my kids my
my family for to maybe sell
no not friends I was [__] his
everything he's Mentor I was already in
Strike Force I had competed against
Gilbert Melendez I Was An established
Pro when he came over to American top
team
um I was living up at American top team
I had an apartment over there for like
about a year and change he broke his hot
his hand his girlfriend had [__]
kicked him out of the place because she
he had given her [__] herpes and [__]
no I'm dead ass serious she had like
nowhere to [__] live so he asked if
he could crash on my couch I was like
yeah [__] it bro we're on both on this
journey together we train together we
played poker together
[__] this and that so I basically fed
this dude for a [__] year lived in my
couch and give me a [__] dollar
because he didn't have a job at a
[__] broken hand it's all document it
saw him on YouTube saying horror imagine
that was my best friend if it wasn't for
Jorge I wouldn't be here and this and
that and then you know um I'm at 155 so
then I come up to 170 and I start
stealing a lot of not stealing but I
start getting a lot of Shine from myself
a lot of eyeballs start looking at me
and immediately instead of like yeah
we're [__] boys we could fight or
whatever whatever the [__] he turns into
something [__] ugly you know like
everything that I did for you you're
trying to use it against me especially
my kids he knows the relationship I have
with my kids and you're trying to use
that against me you're a [__] piece
of [__] but beside before all that
happened I already knew he wasn't a good
person because my uh
my striking coach this is when we cut
ties me and him my striking coach
trained him from his amateur all the way
to his Raphael dosanjos fight and he did
a handshake deal with them five percent
on your fights you know if you make a
thousand dollars you make five hundred
thousand dollars five percent is when
you're gonna pay me because that's what
Joel Romero pays me as well pays me
that's what all the guys are trained
with him pay him you know and he's like
accessible at all times you will drive
an hour this way drive an hour back that
way and just give you all his knowledge
and that's that's what he wanted you
know and uh they shook hands on it as
soon as Kobe made money what did he do
didn't pay my coach so since then I was
like bro I want to [__] take a bite
to his [__] neck and my coaches like
don't do it bro you you'll fight him and
now we're that's how you'll get him for
both of us you know I didn't get him
that time but I promise you before my
career is over I'm gonna [__]
murder Kobe in the cage legally
Legally Legally what happened illegally
allegedly a lot of things happen
allegedly I don't know they're saying a
lot of things by us it's all allegedly
cuz I [__] man allegedly is a great word
yeah I don't know what they're talking
about man but legally in the cage in the
UFC I'm gonna [__] snatch it so one
way or another and
that's also something that you know
losing a piece of [__] like that and you
know like if you let somebody come into
you and and you share something with me
like man something is very dear to me
it's this moment where my mom blah blah
blah and this and that and then I would
use that because me and you had a
falling out it really shows your [__]
character like you're a [__] piece of
[__] bro you know and that's why nobody
[__] with this guy nobody [__] with
this guy in any level in any Accord you
know well it's a crazy Jon Jones can't
stand him yeah he had a very similar
thing with Jon Jones he changed who he
was when the UFC was about to cut him
and he decided to become like a
wrestling heel [__] on a whole country
just for for what like all right it
worked though I mean the thing about it
is it's kind of Genius in the fact that
it really did get people paying
attention to him in a negative way but
you know I feel that he could have just
been beating people put more time into
the craft rather than Twitter and trying
to copy other heels and it would have
been fine like this guy just oh what is
Connor doing today let me go do that on
the cheaper
shittier way you know like be [__]
you bro you know just [__] go out
there and beat dudes up and say what you
got to say and it'll come to you but it
took me a while to get here you know I
had to [__] knock out and beat
numerous [__] people actual Champions
to get here but it'll come you don't
have to sell out for the [__] dollar
bro
what was it like fighting him
um I wanted to [__] kill him I want
to hurt him but it wasn't the best
version of me bro it just wasn't the
best version of me there and you know in
this part that's what I love about it
it's like what happened happened and
everything else is [__] right so
until we fight again nobody will get to
see that better version of me but I
promise you Joe before I close this
chapter in my life in MMA I will have
competed against the sky I'm gonna
[__] take it so bro I I just know it
after being those five rounds in there
with them and that was the best that he
had and I was nowhere near my best at
that time for for different reasons I
knew I could [__] end this guy